Have you read the reviews?
They're good, right?
They're good.  I'm excited
Sophie, I left the heart pills
at  home.  Just relax,
It'll be fine, you haven't had
an incident in forever.
Before today's showing
of Blue Iguana
please welcome
our surprise guest.
The film star Ben Schwartz.
What a big suprise for
everybody.  It's me Ben Schwatz.
How are you?  How're you doing
little boy?  You ok?
He's not good with surprises.
He has a heart condition.
Never been around a big movie
star before?  Is that what it
is?
He's just a little shocked,
you're one of his two favorite
actors.
I'm going to get your pills.
Can you please
take care of him?
So what do you like me from is
it the drama stuff or the comedy
stuff?
Both.  Both, oh what a fan.
You say I'm one
of your favorite actors
who was the other?
Sam Rockwell
you said Sam Rockwell.
Sammy time!  Yeah!   You
don't have to make the noise.
This thing makes the noise.
Sorry I'm late guys.
What's wrong with this guy?
Why are his eyes closed?
Are you sleepy?
He's not feeling to good Sammy.
Sammy.  He can't hear me over...
Sammy he's not feeling to good.
Hey hey hey. Wake up wake up.
Yeah you know what always cheers
me up when I'm a little sleepy.
T-shirt cannon!  T-shirt
cannon!
Why would you shoot him
in the face?
Where else am I going to shoot
him in the feet?
Come on, have you ever shot a
T-shirt cannon before?
No, I'm so stupid.  Come on.
I think he's a goner.
Bet you fifty bucks he lives.
You're on.  Really that quick?
Alright, I love it.
Hey.
Pay up.  Oh yeah baby.
Don't entourage me.
Sophie, Sophie.
What are you saying?
Selfie, selfie. You got it
pal.  Selfie is what you want.
Now us. Now us.
Right on his dick.
That is a mega-fan.
You're not looking very good
though.  Looking bad.
You should crack his chest open.
We should crack open his
chest. We should crack it open.
Maybe a punch in the
middle
Maybe I punch in the
middle.
and separate it
like a... A doctor, doctor.
A doctor.
Maybe like a real doctor.
Don't you know a real doctor?
Good thinking.
You kidding me?
Dude, you really were great
in the movie.  You really think
so?
I really felt like
you invested yourself.
I did, the character to me
was way more than what you see
on the screen.  Days
and days of back work on that.
Hello. Clooney!  George
Clooney? What's happening.
Hey, It's Ben Schwartz.
Hey, so we got a heart victim.
victimize.
I don't know?  Something is
wrong with his heart.
He wants to take a lot of
selfies.
Uh huh, ok got it.   Ben
Schwartz.
He said maybe he needs some
Casamigos. He said he's
not really sure
what the problem is.  Casamigos.
Some baby aspirin and some
tequila.  Does anyone have
any Casamigos?
Anybody have any baby aspirin?
Does anybody have any Vicks
Vaporub?  How bout a little salt
bath?
Does anyone have a full salt
bath for his fee?  I do.
Is he dead?  I think he's a
goner.  Hello?
Yeah that's right pal,
in your face.
Do you really think I was good
in this movie?
Dude I thought you really mixed
the comedy
and the drama and the action.
It's like Meryl Streep, Tom
Cruise, Jason Statham, Daniel
Day-Lewis..
That's what I was going for.
and like Don Knotts. Dude.  You
felt it all.
Incredible.
Does anyone have a one third
used condom?
Just the bottom third.